herzlich willkommen eine demokratische
gesellschaft ist ohne freie debatte
nicht denkbar
aber diese debatte scheint wird es immer
schwerer zu fallen immer mehr themen von
der flüchtlingskrise über den
klimawandel europa die gender debatte
bis hin zu den corona maßnahmen werden
nicht mehr diskutiert sondern
skandalisiert was aber passiert wenn
hass und verachtung regieren wenn wir
mit den anderen überhaupt nicht mehr
reden weil die politische feinde aber
vor allem schlechte menschen sind unser
thema heute polarisiert und unversöhnt
wie gespalten ist unsere gesellschaft
und das sind unsere gäste
wolfgang kubicki der fdp-politiker und
bundestags-vizepräsident mahnt wenn ein
großteil der menschen glaubt sich nicht
mehr frei äußern zu dürfen haben wir ein
demokratieproblem svenja flaßpöhler die
philosophin und chefredakteurin des
philosophie magazins hat selbst schwere
anfeindungen und ein extrem verhängtes
denken erlebt dennoch sagt sie ich bin
weder zensiert noch stumm geschaltet
worden
jan fleischhauer der kolumnist und autor
erhält spaltung in einer demokratie für
das normalste der welt
mir geht nicht so sehr auf die nerven
wie die kuhstall wärme der
gesinnungsgemeinschaft sehr abdullah
die cdu-politikerin und staatssekretärin
für integration in nordrhein westfalen
sagt andere meinungen zuzulassen gehört
zu einer demokratischen streitkultur
nur dürfen wir streit nicht mit hass und
hetze verwechseln
gregor gysi der linken politiker warnt
ich halte die polarisierung in allen
gesellschaften für eine entwicklung die
die demokratie bedroht weil sie nicht
auf den diskurs sondern auf dominanz
zielt
da haben wir es verlernt die anderen
fahren deren abweichende meinungen zu
tolerieren
eine bestandsaufnahme von philipp wunder
so ein virus das die gesellschaft weiter
spaltet eine maske die polarisiert eine
zeit die die menschen auseinander treibt
keine debatte kein diskurs die einen
gelten sofort als nazis die anderen
beschimpft als links grün versifft der
streit über die flüchtlingspolitik 2015
das war nur der anfang themen mit zwei
lager die korona politik klima sexismus
auftrittsverbote und frauenquote
beleidigung und diffamierung inklusive
diskutiert wird selten und ausgegrenzt
fast immer vor bleibt die suche nach dem
konsens ausgrenzung statt diskussion
haben wir verlernt zu streiten
polarisiert und unversöhnt wie gespalten
ist unsere gesellschaft ja zum einstieg
würde ich gerne von jedem von ihnen
zunächst mal hören wie sie dieses thema
sehen also ist unsere gesellschaft
wirklich zunehmend gespalten und vor
allem wo erleben sie das ganz
persönliche kopie ist zunächst einmal
war die gesellschaft immer schon
gespalten oder geradezu bei wichtigen
fragen denken wir mal an die frage der
kernenergie an die frage wo ein endlager
hin soll denkt man die frage ist nach
doppelbeschlusses an die frage der
deutschen ostpolitik ich gehöre dazu die
jungen alten wie gregor gysi auch kann
sage es anfang der 70er jahre das auch
sehr hoch hergehen wir waffen der
bundeswehr
was ich aber erlebe und das ist
vielleicht auch meiner langjährigen
erfahrung geschuldet ist dass wir
mittlerweile eine kultur des bewussten
missverstehen entwickelt haben wo es
nicht mehr darum geht was der andere für
eine meinung hat und wie er sie äußert
sondern was man verstehen will
und darauf aufbauend seine eigene
meinung zu dokumentieren immer mit dem
hauch jetzt der moralischen
überlegenheit das ist das was mir
wirklich auf den sender geht dieser
moralische überlegen dieses moralisch
überlegenheitsgefühl die bei einer
anderen meinung gegenüber andere
persönlichkeiten die es dann auch
teilweise rechtfertigt dass man nicht
nur verbal sondern auch handgreiflich
miteinander umgeht er war alles
aufgreifen flaßpöhler wie erleben sie
das persönlich erlebt dass es sehr
ähnlich ich würde auch sagen dass es
gegenwärtig schon noch mal eine neue
dynamik gibt die unsere zeit abhebt von
früheren zeiten das hat sicher damit zu
tun dass wir in einer extrem
medialisierung gesellschaft leben in
einer hoch emotionalisierten aber auch
ich würde sagen in einer sehr
sensibilisierten zeit also menschen
werden sensibler und deshalb nur diese
moralische überlegenheit kommt ja genau
daher dass man sagen kann erstmal ist es
ja auch gut dass wir sensibler werden
dass wir mehr stimmen hören und so
weiter aber das entwickelt gegenwärtig
eine dynamik dass man sagen kann
vielleicht sind wir dabei dass es kippt
die sie wie gespalten empfinden sie
unsere gesellschaft naja also seit
meiner kindheit weiß ich dass die
gesellschaft hin
gespalten sind es gibt eben ein bei uns
gerade ein norm widerspruch zwischen arm
und reich
frauen haben nicht die gleichen chancen
wie männer in ländern und inländer und
ausländerinnen und ausländer gibt es
widersprüche usw
und jetzt kommen die politischen
widersprüche hinzu die herr kubicki
aufgezählt hat was mir sorgen macht sind
zwei sachen erstens dass die zahl
derjenigen die die etablierte politik
ableben ständig zunimmt sind
darüber müssen wir nachdenken was können
wir nicht einfach so hinnehmen
und das zweite ist dass wir im
augenblick gerade über 80 millionen
biologinnen und biologen verfügen dh der
ausgangspunkt ist ich habe recht und
kein anderer dann hört man auch nicht
mehr zu
also wir die doch maßnahmen
rechtfertigen hören den an nicht zu und
die die sie völlig falsch finden hören
uns nicht mehr zu das macht mir sorgen
weil es so ein streben nach dominant ist
nicht nach ausgleich mal gülle wo sehen
sie zu nehmende hass hetze nimmt es über
dazu man hat zumindest das gefühl dass
es zu nimmt dich wird aber auch meinen
vorrednern in sofort zustimmen dass
diese spaltung der gesellschaft
eigentlich immer existiert hat herr
kubicki hat ja gerade ein paar beispiele
genannt ich will aber auch vielleicht
ein beispiel nehmen 1994 als es um den
asylkompromiss ging das ja vielleicht
mit 2014/2015 er zu vergleichen ist
gebunden
dass abgeordnete in bonn über den sein
mit schiffen in den bundestag gebracht
werden mussten weil es davor so große
demonstrationen gab weil es eine aufruhr
gab innerhalb der bevölkerung innerhalb
der gesellschaft und auch da kann man
vielleicht durch also kann man durchaus
sagen dass die gesellschaft gespalten
war aber ich glaube der entscheidende
punkt ist das was sie gerade auch gesagt
haben das wird medial sehr viel mehr
ausgetragen als das vielleicht 1994 oder
zuvor der fall war
jetzt hat jeder die möglichkeit seinen
eigenen presse spieler auch zu spielen
oder einen eigenen pressesprecher auch
zu spielen eben durch die möglichkeit
der sozialen netzwerke und so entsteht
eben auch diese moralische überlegenheit
dass jeder seine meinung für die absolut
richtige entscheidende und moralisch
wichtigste hält und das sind die welt
zusammen kann und alle anderen meinungen
eigentlich ja zunichte macht oder nicht
nur klein redet sie sondern zu zur not
auch mit denen mit hass und hetze
begegnet us but not least der fleischer
also ich glaube gericht dass die unsere
gesellschaft wirklich gespalten ist also
ob jetzt die leute zum beispiel bei der
bmw werkskantine übereinander herfallen
glaube ich überhaupt nicht da gibt es
schon unterschiede in der politischen
bewertung sondern was gespalten ist
etwas das man das gefühl erweckt dass
unsere gesellschaft gespalten ist dass
bestimmte lager sehr lautstark
vernehmbar sind und oft genannter
einklappen und das was glaube ich was er
was leute stört ist den eindruck dass
bestimmte position medial kaum noch
abgebildet werden
also ich glaube in der korona krise
sehen wir dass wenn sie also
morgenmagazin zdf einschalten also das
jetzt hier sagt darf aber doch ich bin
ihre meinung gesagt wenn sich halt
morgenmagazins pdf oder ard ein und
kriegen sozusagen schon bevor die
kanzlerin ihre rede hält die
entsprechenden virologen präsentiert mit
der düstersten aller annahmen und das
geht so zusagen von montag bis freitag
und dann schlagen sie die süddeutsche
auf und dann lesen sie warum all das was
die kanzlerin jetzt beschlossen und
verkündet hat goldrichtig ist im grunde
noch zu wenig da sagen die leute sich ob
wir ja kann man so sehen aber wo ist
eigentlich die andere
position das empfinde ich als wirkliches
problem
das treibt greifen wir alles alles auf
ich versuche mal mein eindruck zusammen
zu fassen ich hatte den eindruck ich
sagen okay unterschiedliche positionen
eine gespaltene gesellschaft hat immer
schon gegeben
aber was sich intensiviert haben zu
schaffen zu haben ist das dass die
gesprächskultur nicht nicht mehr stimmt
also das würde ich jetzt mal an anfang
einstellen
fehlt da einfach an toleranz sind die
leute nicht mehr in der lage vernünftig
zu streiten und dabei den anderen gelten
zu lassen als mensch habe ja es wird
eigentlich der respekt mittlerweile
zuzuhören auch andere meinungen
zuzulassen eine andere meinung zu
zulassen heißt ja nicht dass ich diese
meinung adaptieren muss dass ich diese
meinung zu meiner meinung machen muss
aber sie muss zumindest einen platz im
öffentlichen raum auch haben meine
einerseits kommt ja auch aus aus aus
dieser ecke besprechen immer über rechte
hater und hat hetzer mitnichten ist es
so kommt eben auch aus der
entgegengesetzten richtung einer vice
president für vielfalt für für eine
weltoffenheit für für toleranz ist aber
selbst auch noch gar nicht in der lage
diese meinungsvielfalt diese toleranz
und diese weltoffenheit geben da auch
andere meinungen zulassen muss auch
vorzuleben und insofern gibt es da schon
schon oder entsteht schon das gefühl
dass man sich manchmal in bäumen bewegt
in sozialen netzwerken auch wo man
tatsächlich dreimal überlegt ob man
seine meinung kundtun kann wie man es
wie man es gerne in dem moment möchte
das ist glaube ich ein ganz
entscheidendes stichwort die sozialen
medien
weil es ist ja nicht so dass die
sozialen medien etwas sichtbar machen
was sowieso schon da ist sondern die
sozialen medien produzieren ein ganz
bestimmtes sprechen und zwar durch ihre
innere logik
es geht um klicks es geht um likes es
geht um aufmerksamkeit also die gesamte
aufmerksamkeitsökonomie bringt ein ganz
anderes sprechen hervor und das ist
glaube ich ein wirklich ein wesentlicher
punkt den man hier berücksichtigen
vielleicht wenn ich an deiner stelle
noch ergänzt macht ist es auch die kürze
also bei twitter kann ich den roman als
post patienten bei bei facebook bei
twitter kann ich das eben nicht deshalb
muss ich es umso umso krasser
zusammenfassen damit die aufmerksamkeit
noch mehr auch ich bin
hinzu kommt aber ist es ja
nicht so dass es vorher diesen streit
nicht gehabt wie sie sagen dem
politischen streit nicht gab jetzt
wittern uhr öffentlich gemacht und
gleichzeitig wird aber auch öffentlich
gerne jemand an den pranger gestellt
egal von welcher seite
das ist ein blog das hatten wir
vielleicht vor 15 jahren in dem in dem
maße noch nicht das thema so unter ihnen
sind einige die es einmal heftig
twittern und ganz viele follower haben
bei bei ihnen beiden nun weit jenseits
von 100 tausend sich glaubt 300.000 sie
sind auch heftig unterwegs bei ihnen
herr kubicki ich glaube sie zittern
überhaupt nicht bei sie auch richtig
finde sie hat eine ganz ganz interessant
also hier so eine gemeinsame analyse so
twitter und diese echoraum ist schuld
aber ganz andere konsequenz drei von
ihnen twittern und es war es gar nicht
die sozialen medien den effekt haben
jeweils auf die gesellschaft den willen
unterstellen die meisten deutschen sind
gar nicht auf twitter ich glaube es sind
drei und es sind wahrscheinlich als ich
13 prozent der deutschen aber 93 prozent
der journalisten
all diesen alle offiziere daher also das
heißt in unserer welt ist ein ganz
wichtiges medium
ich glaube eher im gegenteil das ist ein
problem viele redaktionen und auch
chefredakteure dass sie das viel zu
ernst nehmen diese letztlich relativ
kleine gruppe von menschen die
wahnsinnig lautstark jetzt sich
wahnsinnig schnell erregt das ist aber
gar nicht die leser da gibst du
verwendest du bist schon mal sehen ist
gab auch nie tue ja also es gab es gibt
einfach ganze bewegungen die extreme
kraft gerade aber auch soziale medien
entwickeln auf lassen
das ist eine ganz kleine bewegung lässt
sich gewesen ich glaube da yahoo auf der
höhepunkt der methode button wurde
aufgerufen zu einer demonstration am
brandenburger tor um den sexismus in
deutschland endlich die stirn zu bieten
ich habe es vergessen wie viele
teilnehmer waren aber ungelogen es waren
glaube ich 43 oder 73 es waren nicht
mehr aber feines future ist das ring
beispiel dass es auch eine bewegung die
in den sozialen netzwerken durch
jugendliche entstanden ist wo sie sich
vernetzen konnten und somit ganz ganz
viele auf die straße gegangen sind also
ich war ich kenne die zahlen von mietern
nicht aber es gibt durchaus bewegungen
die durch die sozialen netzwerke noch
mal wirklich motorisierte wurden es sind
auch nicht mehr als 15 prozent der
jugendlichen insgesamt gewesen also die
behauptung das sei die jugend wir
schlicht und ergreifend falsch weil die
mehrheit der jugendlichen sich dafür
nicht interessiert aber es hat nicht nur
auf die straße gehen alleine das thema
bei so
jugend ich sagen es war thema bei 15 der
juni darüber dass wissenschaftliche
studien und 15 prozent der jugendlichen
haben die traditionellen öffentlich
rechtlichen medien die jugend gemacht
oder die menschen haben davon gesprochen
dass die jugend es ist nicht die jugend
kann ich jetzt sage ich immer schon
gesagt komme ich mir eine berufsschule
oder an den wirtschafts akademie
dann werden sie feststellen dass leute
die dort sind sich für frösche future
überhaupt nicht interessieren oder ganz
andere position
ich glaube nicht dass es um die sozialen
netzwerke haben die geschwindigkeit der
informationsbeschaffung sondern der
informationsdarstellung wenn ich mit
journalisten rede und dann mal wieder
frage warum das interview was er gemacht
haben mit einer überschrift versehen
wird ja die damit nichts zu tun hat dann
heißt es immer wieder kubicki bei uns
geht jetzt online und klicks und dann
können sie in dem video erfahren war so
nur überschrift das reicht ja auch mal
angeklickt zu werden das ist nämlich die
die währung mit der werbezeiten verkauft
werden oder mit der man werbung auch ein
leben können aber ich erlebe das jetzt
wirklich selbst ich präsidiere im
deutschen bundestag und kriege während
der zwei stunden ich präsentiere
mindestens drei anfragen von
publikationsorgan was ich zu einem
bestimmten punkt sage denen ich gar
nicht habe wahrnehmen können sich dort
präsentieren und auf meine mitteilung
ich kann ja nicht halb stunden antworten
kriege ich die antwort dann sind sie
draußen so anfang ist das also sagen der
gruppe völlig recht ich verstehe auch
nie ein zwischenruf aber reagiere immer
drauf weil ich denke er wird schon und
was gesagt damit zu tun hat weiß ich
auch nicht nein es gibt einen fehler in
der politik zwei fehler über die ich mir
wirklich gedanken mache und das ist
jetzt gar nicht gegen andere gerichtet
das eine ist die falsche sprache also
dann sprechen wir wirklich im bundestag
über die veräußerungserlös gewinn steuer
und kein mensch übersetzt
das geht nicht wir sind volksvertreterin
volksvertreter ich mache das dann
natürlich mit selbstironie und sage noch
mal ganz langsam damit dass einer wie
ich auch versteht und dann übersetze ich
aber das habe ich als anwalt schon
gelernt
dh unsere sprache ist falsch und das
zweite ist es gibt einen politischen
vorgang der interessantes die finden und
ein kompromiss in der koalition dass es
das erste und dann sagen sie wie
verkaufen wir den kompromiss
das heißt sie nennen sich ihre
wirklichen beweggründe sondern solche
von denen sie hoffen dass die mehrheit
der bevölkerung sie akzeptiert das weiß
die bevölkerung nicht so aber sie spürt
es der instinkt dafür
das heißt bevor ich andere kritisieren
müssen wir erstmal über uns nachdenken
was wir vielleicht falsch machen und wo
wir die nähe zu den leuten verloren
das zweite ist dass die social medien
schon einen einfluss haben er wird zum
teil überschätzt das stimmt aber man
darf es auch nicht unterschätzen
nur und das kritisiere ich genau wie sie
die gegenposition bei corona kommt in
den medien so gut wie nicht vor und das
geht nicht selbst wenn das dann harte
auseinandersetzungen werden aber die
einseitigkeit geht den leuten auch
wieder auf die nerven und dann behaupten
sie natürlich dass er alles
gleichgeschaltet und von oben das ist
alles wieder unsinn
aber diesen unsinn anzugehen wird nicht
leichter sondern immer schwerer
ich möchte direkt dazu was sage du hast
weil das fast ganz schön zusammen sagt
wollen wir wir haben in der politik eine
elitäre sprache die wir nicht übersetzen
aber ich finde es interessant dass in
der korona krise eigentlich eine
infantilisierung sprache verwendet
yamaha regeln usw
ja also ich muss sagen bei mir kräuselt
sich da alles wir müssen die zügel
anziehen das aus und ja aber eben auch
dass das das und da finde ich auch da
muss man auch die öffentlich-rechtlichen
wirklich kritisieren es ist eine eine
hoch emotionalisierte berichterstattung
ja also wie viele beiträge ich jetzt
gestern abend wieder im heute journal
darüber gesehen haben wie angehörige
trauern um ihre verstorbenen und dass
sie verstorben dann alleine und so
weiter aber ich erfahre zum beispiel
nichts über das was diese impfstoffe
eigentlich genau können also verhindern
sie nur dass die kasse bei mir ausbricht
oder verhindert sie ansteckungen ich
damit verändert sich alle mal schimpfen
china russland und großbritannien
und dann fragen sich die leute warum wir
nicht keine ahnung haben also verstehen
sie denn sagen die wir sind noch nicht
soweit oder das muss man noch genauer
prüfen das macht sie alle unruhig jetzt
soll der impfstoff kommen alle hoffen
dann sind alle probleme gelöst aber doch
nicht in einer woche wenn überhaupt
wir sind ja mittendrin in der debatte
aber wo sie sich da jetzt alle auf die
öffentlich rechtlichen medien
einschießen ist ja immer schwierig wenn
man als moderator in eigener sache was
sagt aber erlauben sie mir mal zwei
argumente wir haben jede menge umfragen
das vertrauen in die öffentlich
rechtlichen medien ist nicht gesund
sondern so hoch wie noch nie hat 1 und a
2 ich kann ihnen gerne gesellschaften
oder öffentlich-rechtliche medien denn
zb die usa
da ist unser thema die spaltung der
gesellschaft noch mal eins drauf das
soll nicht alles rechtfertigen und macht
eigentlich der abschaffung des
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk sich bei
der kripo erkennen und das lassen sie
mal etwas und naja da findet ja auch die
regierungspolitik richtig aber die
minderheit von weiss ich fast 20 prozent
deren meinung ist ja nicht teile
aber sie muss zu wort kommen auch in den
öffentlich rechtlichen medien und eben
nicht nur in den social media finden sie
mich voll auf ihrer seite
multi perspektive thet ist etwas was
sich alle medien und wir auch auf die
fahnen schreiben sollten und der
teilweise auch tun
ich würde gern 1 aufgreifen und weil
massive im eingangsstatement auch gesagt
haben und zwar es gibt die andere
meinung und das ist ja auch prima wenn
es die andere meinungen gibt aber wir
haben so eine zunehmende tendenz dass
der andere nicht einer ist der eine
andere meinung hat sondern dass ein
schlechter mensch weil wer sowas denkt
muss ein schlechter mensch sein
es ist das eine veränderung in unserer
debatte dass wir nicht mehr anerkennen
dass es andere meinungen gibt sondern
wir immer gleich glauben die andere
meinung ist was schlechtes das fängt mit
der flüchtlings debatte an
ist doch klar die ihnen die flüchtlinge
aufnehmen wollten hielten jene die sie
ausgrenzen wollten für schlechte
menschen also nicht nur das ist ein
traum ein bock hatten sondern für
schlechte menschen verstehe auch die
überlegung aber man muss sich immer
überlegen wozu das führt weil es dann
kein gespräch mehr gibt und das ist das
problem
herr kubicki und ich wir haben natürlich
in wirtschaftlichen fragen auch höchst
unterschiedliche auffassungen nicht
wiederum was die liberalität betrifft
haben wir zum beispiel ähnlich aber ich
halte doch seine unterschiedlichen
auffassungen aus und er auch meine das
heißt wir haben nie das gespräch
ausgeschlossen
und da weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht wie
wir das wieder hinkriegen wie viel mal
interessieren woran liegt das denn also
warum warum halte ich jemand der eine
andere meinung hat plötzlich ein
schlechter mensch wurde weil das setzt
ja voraus natürlich ein idealzustand
dass ich als sprechender andermann des
anderen wirklich interessiert wäre und
wir gewissermaßen die so heißt die
debatte diskus
eintreten die wirklichkeit ist folgende
wenn sie die regeln bestimmen als
politische gruppe also diese zusagen sie
sitzen am tisch
dann sind sie zunächst überhaupt gar
keine veranlassung dass leute die eine
ganz andere meinung haben
da auch platz nehmen und das war wohl
sagen wir mal wenn wir uns ein bisschen
zurückgehen 1968 so da saßen neben im
wesentlichen konservative an diesem
tisch und dann kam diese jungen 68er und
sagt wir wollen da auch sitzen dann
haben die alten alles erst mal dafür
unternommen dass die jungen da nicht
sitzen und wann haben sie es geschafft
habe sich umgedreht was wir heute haben
ist aus meiner sicht das eben in der
kulturell medialen welt die linken
winter so rot grünen regieren also
möchte ich ihnen eher näher stehen
das ist ja auch durch alle umfragen
abgesichert und nun kommen sozusagen
andere in diesem fall neu von rechts und
sagen wir wollen jetzt da auch mit
sprechen und da sag ich doch wenn ich da
sitze
warum eigentlich und übernehme versuchen
natürlich alles zu unternehmen um die
rauszuhalten und ein mittel zum beispiel
andere herauszuhalten ist
stigmatisierung das heißt zu sagen also
deine meinung ist nicht nur eine meinung
sondern die ist entweder demokratie für
verfassungsfeindlich rechts nazi das
muss im zweifel auch gar nicht begründen
ich heiße ich klebe jemandem anderen
etikett auf die stirn um zu sagen du
darfst an diesem tisch wo wir alle
miteinander reden nicht platz nehmen
das ist erstmal ein kampfmittel insofern
ist das was wir als cancel culture
bezeichnen oder anderen begriffe es ist
ein mittel der politischen
auseinandersetzung wenn man es sagen wir
mal ganz kalt betrachtet darf ich greife
es geht vielleicht noch ein bisschen
tiefer bei 2 problemlagen die wir gerade
haben das eine ist der klimawandel das
an der asco ohne wir hören immer wieder
die wissenschaft weiß einen den weg und
es gibt nur diesen einen weg nun lebt
wissen schafft das wissen wir davon dass
auch widersprüchliche aussagen der
wissenschaftler bei der frage der
bekämpfung der korona krise gibt es
geologen die sagen die wissenschaft geht
in diese richtung und dann kommen andere
wissenschaftler und die können einfach
nicht mehr dazu weil sie nicht auf dem
stand sind oder nicht der richtige weg
beschreiben können beim klima wilson
wird es noch schlimmer
ich habe probiert mal einen brief
geschrieben in dem er freundschaftlich
robert wenn du tatsächlich glaubst also
nur einen weg gibt den klimawandel zu
bekämpfen da musst du demokratie und
rechtsstaat abschaffen und an all
diejenigen die das anders sehen dies
anders wählen oder gerichte anrufen die
führen ja dann dazu dass der klimawandel
bekämpft werden kann sondern die
menschheit von der erde verschwindet
also ist die überlegung
es gibt nur diesen einen weg und dem ist
nicht alle unterordnen demokratie fallen
die ich unrechtsstaats freundlich und
diniert den diskus diskus filme momentan
auch bei der bekämpfung der korona krise
wenn ich sage machen wir es doch so wie
der tübinger bürgermeister in die wir
tatsächlich altenpfleger mit fb zwei
masken ausstatten keiner kommt mehr rein
der nicht der fdp zwar etwas gekauft und
die bediensteten und die pflegekräfte
und die und die reinigungskräfte werden
zweimal mit getestet er hat keine
infektion bei über-50-jährigen tübingen
dann heißt es das ist der falsche weg
wir brauchen kontakt begrenzungen herr
wieder fordert uns jetzt auf einige dass
wir auch weihnachten in der familie
masken tragen sollen ich habe schon
gefragt ich meine frau küssen solche
maske auf habe also dass es da sieht man
dass leute 2 was im keller gelegt haben
die ganze zeit jetzt ans licht der
öffentlichkeit kommen und davon nicht
wieder lassen wollen es gibt nicht nur
den einen weg sind von der weise was zu
bekämpfen und die das behaupten die
machen sich eigentlich schuldig einen
demokratischen diskurs der für uns
dringend notwendig wie der frage parade
das problem war dass ich zumindest
empfinden ist ein bisschen die
pauschalisierung auch gerade in der
debatte die an manchen punkten um etwas
zu vereinfachen deutlich zu machen
richtig sein kann aber an an dieser
stelle eben nicht meine wir haben gerade
eine kleine schelte sage ich jetzt mal
oder kritik wer fleisch aber das
formuliert hat an die an die
öffentlich-rechtlichen nach der letzten
regierungserklärung ich hätte man jetzt
nicht die haushaltsdebatte gestern nach
der letzten regierungserklärung der
kanzlerin beim heute-journal und ich
glaube auch in den tagesthemen alles
weitere eingeladen als
oppositionsführerin und wenn man dann
sagt ihnen öffentlich rechtlichen medien
kommt die meinung der opposition aber
oder diejenigen die das kritisch sehen
überhaupt nicht in frage dann widerlegt
dieser auftritt dann zeige ich würde
gerne auch noch mal darauf haben sie die
an- und abmoderation bekommen also ich
habe die ich habe die ganze sendung mit
gesehen gesehen ja und normal also es
ist nicht richtig dass man hier irgendwo
den vorwurf macht dass die menschen die
das kritisch sehen oder
man ist es ja mehr als kritik was die
fdp zumindest bezirk überhaupt nicht
mehr zu wort kommen auch in denen auch
in den printmedien nicht und das ist
dass das andere was sie was sie gerade
sagten ist ja man mag das manchmal
banalisieren man manchmal dass das
rechtens ins lächerliche ziehen und
etwas was der tübinger oberbürgermeister
gemacht hat ist noch mal das eine aber
ich glaube auch da muss man
unterscheiden ob ich in die all die
maßnahmen für die einschränkung der
meinungsfreiheit halte für den untergang
der demokratie wie ich argumentiere oder
ob ich sage ich habe kein problem mit
bestimmten maßnahmen ob setzt die
schließung von der gastronomie ist ob
sie jetzt und davor noch die
sperrstunden dazu das kann man alles
kritisch diskutieren aber es kommt ein
bisschen immer auf das maß an
und diejenigen die dieses maß eben
völlig völlig überziehen die muss ich
ehrlich gesagt auch nicht rechtfertigen
und ihre kritik auch tatsächlich als
kritik sehen sondern dann ist es eben
pauschal etwas ins lächerliche ziehen in
einer verdammt ernst wird wird gerne
noch mal ganz kurz was dazu sagen weil
ich glaube man kann die situation auch
genau von der anderen seite beschreiben
sie haben vorhin gesagt ja die idee
spitze ist jetzt mal so ein bisschen zu
die medien sind irgendwie so ein
bisschen linksliberal vor allem besetzt
und die rechten die dürfen
die dürfen im grunde nicht so richtig
was sagen die kommen von außen wir
wollen da irgendwie von außen rein und
das geht aber nicht
man kann es natürlich auch genau
umgekehrt beschreiben und sagen wir
leben einfach in einer zeit in der viel
viel mehr perspektiven gehört werden
von schwarzen von transsexuellen usw
homosexuellen und ich beschreibe jetzt
sozusagen die sicht von der anderen
seite und die privilegierten ja also
stichwort der alte weiße mann der
irgendwie auf den posten sitzt der hat
jetzt ein bisschen sorge um seine
freunde und daraus resultiert der ganze
konflikt und ich würde sagen beide haben
recht sie haben recht aber diese andere
perspektive so ganz falsch ist die auch
nicht und natürlich kann man kann man
sagen dass das letzten endes sagen wir
mal die linke wenn man das jetzt mal so
allgemein sagen kann indem sie sich
sozusagen verantwortlich dafür fühlt
dass die minderheiten repräsentiert
werden dass diskriminierte nicht
diskriminiert werden
haben sie natürlich wenn man so will die
humanität im rücken das ist ja erstmal
eine dynamik so mechanisch erstmal gar
nicht schlecht finden
in erster linie geht es den leuten und
die glaubwürdigkeit der medien sondern
wir müssen uns ja mit der gesellschaft
darüber hinaus befassen und sehen sie
die zwei größten kultur sprünge die ich
in meinem leben erlebt darüber leben an
meine zeit als kind denke und heute als
ich ein kind war in ganz deutschland gab
es nur deutsche küche
das hat sich internationalisiert in
einer art und weise dass man inzwischen
selbst schon in london essen kann was
früher sehr schwer war
weil es eben das chinesische das
italienische das recht und die zweite
sache ist als ich ein kind bahn waren
zwei männer die sich liebten eingesperrt
heute dürfen sie heiraten in einem leben
überwunden eine aber tausendjährige
diskriminierung das finde ich eigentlich
toll und das stimmt wenn ich an diesen
ganzen bereich denke haben wir im
verkehr die und jetzt erleben wir eine
gegenbewegung sowie der nationale
egoismus glaubt das gegenstück zur
globalisierung zu sein
so gibt es jetzt menschen in unserer
gesellschaft die fühlen sich fremd die
die haben den eindruck sie werden gar
nicht mehr beachtet und der fehler den
wir machen bei den gegnern von corinna
ist sie gleich zu setzen
sie sind ihm höchst unterschiedlich auch
in ihren motiven etc
und da müssen wir auch differenzierter
herangehen und dann sind sie sofort
beleidigt wenn man sie alle in ein top
wird natürlich gibt es da
rechtsextremisten aber es gibt doch
nicht nur rechtsextremist es gibt auch
ganz andere dorthin protestiert so und
da müssen wir glaube ich vorsichtiger
werden also wir haben einen gewinn an
kultur das habe ich in meiner
beschrieben aber eben auch verluste als
dagegen relativ sicher ist das natürlich
etwas mit also wenn wir reden hier über
repräsentation also finde ich mich mit
meiner meinung abgebildet zb in den
medien das natürlich nicht nur der
öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk ich habe
ja unter anderem auch die süddeutsche
genannt oder nicht oder in einem schritt
weiter habe ich das gefühl ich bin nicht
nur nicht abgebildet sondern meine
meinung wird auch noch stigmatisiert als
eine die entweder rückschrittlich
veraltet lächerlich ist so und wenn der
teil derjenigen zu groß wird die dieses
gefühl hat dann haben wir ein problem in
der gesellschaft ich glaube das was wir
im augenblick merken auch an zorn an wut
ist genau diese repräsentations lücke
wenn wir es so wollen
also dass leute den eindruck haben es
gibt sondern eine art eben media medial
kulturelle schicht die hat gewisse
vereinbarungen getroffen wie die welt zu
sehen ist wie auch über die welt zu
sprechen ist was die richtigen
sprachkurs sind welche witze machen darf
und welche auf keinen fall gehen welche
straßen und dann gibt es sozusagen gibt
es eben diese seite gibt es viele leute
ja gar nicht mehr mitkommen kosten und
der wiese adler und diese art von
unbehagen auch zorn der daraus anwächst
übrigen wenn man leuten ständig sagt
naja so wie du redest und denkst so hat
man vor 20 jahren geredet so redet man
heute nicht mehr als das heißt du bist
doch zurückgeblieben das gefühl von
zurückgebliebenen bündelt sich
irgendwann und die gruppe kann relativ
groß sein wie wir in amerika gesehen
haben das ist ja der wesentliche motiv
jemand wie sonnenstrom zu wählen das
sind das sind leute die den ganzen tag
gehört zu hören bekommen haben von
sozusagen den politischen eliten dass
sie die zurückgebliebenen sind
diejenigen wie es obama ausgedrückt hat
die noch an an waffen und der bibel
hängen ja die haben es dann aber ganz
schön gezeichnet natürlich haben wir
haben jetzt eine ganze menge von
statements da gehört die alle so in
diese richtung gehen okay diese politik
inkorrekten erstes gefühl von manchen
leuten sie können ihre meinung nicht
sagen
die iss ist ein treiber dieser
entwicklung wird mal gerne umdrehen
politik in konnten es hat ja auch einen
senior nämlich politisch korrektes
möchte denen eine stimme verleihen die
bisher immer diskriminiert wurden also
man kann politisch korrekt es ja auch
als ein mittel verstehen demokratischen
diskurs überhaupt zu ermöglichen weil
man bisher dem diskriminierte menschen
erstmal auf dieselben aber die frage ist
eben was ist diskriminierung und wo
verläuft die grenze des zumutbaren
darüber streiten wer was ist denn
zumutbaren herr sage es ist ja nicht
sollen die jetzt eine stimme haben die
bisher diskriminiert worden sondern
haben die das recht zu sagen die anderen
müssen jetzt schweigen
ich will erst einmal gesagt ein beispiel
deutlich machen dass auf der hannes
schmid der als eine art eine kolumnistin
der taz geschrieben hat dass
polizeibeamte müsen auf den müllhaufen
gehören die habe ich eh nicht will
prinzessin polizisten seien sein soll
wir hörten auf den müllhaufen da gehören
sehen die stecken habe ich mich darüber
öffentlich erst vier genau wie ich
alexander gauland im deutschen bundestag
eine rüge dafür erteilt wird also die
integrationswerkstatt der
bundesregierung der anatolien entsorgen
wollte weil es sorgen bilder im
deutschen bundestag standing ovations
und weil man kommentar zu der
kolumnistin ein shitstorm ohne in der
wirklich beleidigung mit der
formulierung die frau hatte rechts hoch
zu sprechen denn sie war erst eine frau
mit migrationshintergrund und eigener
polizeigewalt erfahrung im gegensatz zu
mir und deshalb sollte ich dazu schweigt
aber das ist interessant wenn ich das
ganz kurz sagen darf nämlich die die
frage der betroffenen perspektive und
der nichtbetroffenen subjektive das ist
das ist wirklich ein interessantes
problem und was glaube ich gegenwärtig
auch eine völlig falsche richtung geht
weil ich glaube dass in gewissen kreisen
die meinung vorherrscht nur betroffene
können zu bestimmten themen etwas sagen
wenn nicht betroffen ist wie herr
kubicki kann zu bestimmten themen nicht
sagen und das ist natürlich einfach
wirklich da muss ich wirklich sagen das
ist totaler quatsch
also weil erstens leben wir alle in
einer gesellschaft das ist eine aus
handlungs sache und es ist ja rein rein
erkenntnis theoretisch so dass wenn ich
betroffen bin dass ich dann vielleicht
manche dinge sehr genau sehe und
vielleicht manche dinge auch besser weiß
aber es ist ja so dass erfährt jeder der
schon mal eine psychotherapie gemacht
hat dass der der nicht betroffen ist
andere dinge sieht die man selber nicht
sieht also das heißt man braucht gerade
ja nicht betroffenen preis war allgemein
hat ihre position interessieren weil als
integrationsbeauftragte sind sie ja
gerade dazu verantwortlich dafür dass
eine diskriminierte gruppe in die
gesellschaft integriert wird und gehör
findet absolut ich möchte aber trotzdem
das was vorhin gesagt wurde
unterstreichen und 1000 ausrufezeichen
dahinter machen weil das problem ist wir
haben gerade das stichwort
differenzierung genannt so und das
natürlich auch in der migrations oder
integrationsdebatte selten differenziert
wird und zwar auch von denjenigen die
sich für sich beanspruchen
da die beste meinung oder die richtige
meinung zu haben weil sie ja selbst
betroffen sind so es wird aber in dieser
debatte gar nicht mehr diskriminiert
wenn wir über diskriminierung oder
rassismus sprechen dann wird das
indianerkostüm was man zu karneval
gerade im weinland liebend gerne trägt
ohne einfachstes zu sein
ich habe selbst so ein kostüm in meiner
in meinem schrank weil ich karnevalisten
bin und die nsu morde die werden fast
auf
eine stufe gestellt so wo man denkt also
leute ihr könnt doch nicht bei dem einen
genauso über rassismus sprechen wie bei
dem anderen
da wird überhaupt nicht mehr die frau
dann seht alle her und entschieden dass
theilig wichtigen anmalen denke ich das
so hat das neumodische wort people of
colour nicht mehr nicht mehr in den mund
nehmen sondern immer noch von menschen
mit migrationsgeschichte spreche was ich
tue als integrationsstaatssekretär weil
ich finde es passt er auch in unserer
sprache
dann wird mir schon unterstellt dass ich
eigentlich nicht auf höhe der zeit was
die diskussionen rund um das thema
integration und migration betreffen
andererseits nehmen ich mir das recht
aber also nicht ich persönlich jetzt
aber derjenige der meint dieses wort sei
jetzt das absolut richtige war herr
kubicki zu sagen der alte weiße mann so
ich würde an seiner stelle das schon
auch von zuzuhören
das tun sie nicht aber weil ich denke
okay wenn eine diskussion so anfängt
dass mir mein gegenüber unterstellt ich
wäre 20 jahre mit meiner meinung nur
durch hinterherhinken
ich würde überhaupt nicht mehr auf höhe
der zeit sein da muss ich ihnen sagen da
wäre doch da ist doch eigentlich gar
keine diskussion debattenkultur mehr
auch ich dass man dem anderen noch so so
ist meine mission immer alles schall
gewann hat zum beispiel dass die männer
so vehement gegen abtreibung auftreten
da sage ich immer dass sie nie schwanger
werden können und das auch nie waren und
das nie erlebt habe etwas vorsicht beim
meinungsäußerung würde ich da sozusagen
durchaus akzeptieren aber das heißt
natürlich nicht dass heißt natürlich
nicht einfach nur die frauen entscheiden
ob abtreibung ist ja nicht so der alle
bundestagsabgeordneten entscheiden ja
darüber nur dass man eine solche
leidenschaft entwicklung entwickelt
gegen abtreibung obwohl man die
situation selber nie durchmachen muss da
wäre ich einfach ein bisschen
vorsichtiger aber natürlich sollen sie
darüber auch reden insofern unterstütze
ich das ja es muss nicht etwa selbst
erlebt haben um es beurteilen zu können
und wenn ich es selbst erlebt habe weiß
ich auf der einen seite mehr auf der
anderen seite war allgemeinere ich
unzulässig wenn zum beispiel sagen alle
polizisten auf dem kein wort mehr
aufklären wenn ich bestohlen werden oder
beraubt werden darf der nicht eingreifen
die linie alle auf müll so das meinen
natürlich nicht aber die so völlig
unzulässige vereinen und natürlich
völlig daneben wiederum wenn es wirklich
polizeigewalt gibt die nicht
gerechtfertigt ist die nicht angemessen
ist müssen wir dagegen auch konsequenter
vorgehen weil das der vergangenheit
geschehen ist also verstehen sie ich
verstehe immer woher was kommt und dann
die so völlig unzulässigen
verallgemeinerungen nur ein satz von
herrn schröder sand aber die person
stolz drauf der sagte zu dieser politik
gibt es keine alternative da hab ich
gesagt dann müssen wir die opposition
verbieten wenn er sowieso keine
alternativen gibt
und dann hat das geändert und sagte seit
dem zu dieser politik gibt es keine
vernünftigen alternativen über diese
natürlich alle hergefallen die diesen
diese kolumne geschrieben habe die
polizisten gehörten zu ihresgleichen auf
dem müll
da hab ich dann irgendwann auch gedacht
na ja also das war jetzt eine kolumne in
der taz verbreitung 15.000 das ist die
höchste auflage die platz erreicht nun
also diese es gibt so eine bereitschaft
auch übel zu nehmen
sie haben das vorhin auch machen sagt
also erstmal den anderen misszuverstehen
über zunehmen gekränkt zu sein
diese unendliche empfindsamkeit und
beleidigt hat das geht mir noch viel
mehr als wenn dann ist mir schon lieber
einig so eine kolumnistin die man so
richtig hingelangt ja als jemand der die
ganze zeit dieses beet schwester tun was
so auch im journalismus einzug gehalten
haben darf ich das eigentlich noch sagen
gibt es dann vielleicht jemanden der
beleidigt sein könnte und gekränkt sein
könnte oder schreibe ich lieber nicht
sprechen natürlich jetzt pro domo als
lohn ist ja ich bin ja sozusagen meine
ganzen heroin im journalismus man immer
spalteholz gewannen riesen spalter karl
kraus allerdings anderes gemacht hat am
ende aber dann ist halt einzeln
australier aber ich glaube dass zwischen
denen die sehr sehr vorsichtig sind nur
nicht anecken wollen und denen die
irgendwie bewusst bestimmte tabus
brechen da gibt es natürlich eine
gemeinsamkeit sie wollen gefallen
sie wollen aufmerksamkeit haben die
einen ein negativer die andere positive
und was ich erleben im journalismus und
das stimmt mich wirklich bedenklich dass
immer mehr kollegen und kolleginnen
tatsächlich darauf achten ob ich sag
jetzt mal die tanzlehrerin das auch
leicht oder nicht ja wenn man das
mahnmal das so schreibt und so um
na dann kriegt man vielleicht nicht so
viele likes und so also das heißt diese
diese diese schere im kopf die die
beginnt langsam zu wirken und das ist
aber nicht weil da irgendein sensor
steht sondern weil man selber auch ich
sags mal so kleines nicht verstand also
ich höre ja von eben jetzt raus ok
politik correctness das ist ein grund
übel und das trägt zu dieser spaltung
dabei gleichzeitig sagen sie aber ganz
vehement ich als waffe gebraucht werden
sagen sie aber ganz vehement so ein
kommentar wie der in der taz wo es heißt
polizisten gehören auf den müll
das geht nicht also das ist ja wie
gesagt das hat keiner das schreiben aber
man darf dann auch eine andere
auffassung äußern das ist der punkt
verstehen sie es gibt grenzen die
beleidigungen gegen frau künast ihr
zunächst das landgericht in vollem
umfang genehmigt hat dann haben sie sich
selbst korrigiert dann haben sie sich
selbst gehört das geht einfach zu weit
also es gibt keinen zur überschreitung
aber innerhalb dieser grenzen darf eine
meinung geäußert werden selbst wenn ich
sie falsch wenn er kann dann seine gegen
meinung äußern da kann man auch wieder
dagegen ist das okay das ist nicht okay
wenn jemand schreibt präsentieren
genau da sind wir bei dem problem wenn
die gleichen leute bei der gleichen
aussage wenn ich foul an trüge
applaudieren bei der gleichen aussage
und wenn ich jemand von der taz
kritisiere ich mich beschimpfen dann
haben wir das problem weil es ja nicht
nur um die aussage geht die monster
sondern es geht nur darum sondern es ist
nur eine treppe standards und ist ja
auch so riesenthema also das natürlich
genau all das ist also ich finde immer
sollte das ist jedenfalls versuchen
grundsätzlich versuche treu zu bleiben
dass ich meine meine maßstäbe nicht
ständig danach ausrichte ob es mir
politisch in den kram passt oder nicht
so und das wäre genau so einen fall also
entweder als er ich kann nicht auf der
einen seite ständig sagen hey speech ist
ganz schlimm und dann laut der hate
speech seminare machen und mich doch im
zweifel der bundesregierung mit einer
million euro dafür im jahr finanzieren
lassen dass ich gegen hate speech kämpfe
wie die neuen deutschen medienmacher und
wie diese ganzen gruppen heißen und dann
gleichzeitig bei so einem fall wenn es
dann gegen die richtigen angeblich gegen
die polizisten
ja ja ja die kann man gar nicht genug
bereiten da muss man sich überlegen was
wir haben also das beispiel bauland
wurde ja gewandt um das zitat da waren
sie glaube ich noch nicht vize-präsident
er hat beim einzug in den bundestag
gesagt wir werden sie jagen
dieser satz wurde extrem zu recht
kritisiert rauf runter jeder hat seine
meinung dazu
dazu gesagt so und diejenigen die das
vernichtend fand in diesem satz haben
der kolumnistin zu dieser kolumne
applaudiert fanden das ganz stark und
ich sehe den unterschied nicht zwischen
wir werden sie jagen und sie gehören
alle auf eine mülheimer wir haben den
scheine pro t sogar ausgelassen fand ich
die entscheidende vororte war da
aufregen über diesen satz wir werden sie
jagen war dass diese sagt schon mal
gefallen war
20 jahre vorher als die grünen in den
bundestag eingezogen waren und gesagt
hatten einer der spitzengrünen
und wir werden sie jagen kohl und diese
banden das hatten damals alle in ordnung
da würde ich auch mal moment aber ich
muss trotzdem nochmal differenzieren
weil natürlich die ich versuche jetzt
mal so ein bisschen von den konkreten
fällen wegzuziehen aber sagen wir mal
die die linke hate speech
die richtet sich erstmal gegen wiederum
zugespitzt privilegierte ja so also auch
die polizei ist jetzt sagen wir mal
insgesamt keine randgruppe
während natürlich die hate speech von
rechts richtet sich in der regel eben
gegen menschen mit migrationshintergrund
gegen randgruppen kriegen kannst
transsexuell und so der politiker
zweiter des deutschen bundestages weder
von rechts khalifa und bombardiert und
das sollen dass das stimmt aber ich
trotzdem gibt es natürlich schon diese
diesen unterschied aber wie gesagt
trotzdem die meinungsfreiheit also in
den grenzen des gegenverkehrs genannt
habe logischerweise nicht beschränken
dass man selber von sich überzeugt es
als von anderen das liegt doch im
menschen also mein vater hat einmal
gesagt es gibt so viel bauland wir
werden sie entsorgen als er über die
damalige integration zwar auf
brachte der bundesregierung also ist was
nicht keine wo es kein vergleich vor 20
jahren gibt weil dieser satz genau da
das erste mal von einem
bundestagsfraktionsvorsitzenden
parteivorsitzenden in deutschland so
gefallen ist wir werden eine politiker
und mit migrationsgeschichte in
anatolien hat er ja noch gesagt
entsorgen so zwischen dem und auf den
müllhaufen verbrennen oder auch den
ölhafen abschied gibt es keinen
unterschied so man darf aber nicht
weiter steigen
man kann aber nicht einerseits dass eine
kritisieren vernichten mit der kritik
unter sandra jubeln gekommen jetzt
einfach nicht mehr der sicherheits mit
kommt es aber nur darauf an zu sagen es
gibt dennoch ein unterschied sichtlich
zudem gibt es das wird mich jetzt ja
schon interessieren ob star konnten
konsens gibt in der runde
also hats von links geschieht aus edlen
motiven als hat von recht und sagen das
habe ich nicht gesagt ist als strafe
verstanden wenn die leute von der rega
straße oder im daniel vor dass
polizeibeamte verprügeln dann gibt es
teilweise applaus dafür und keine
ablehnung
wenn hooligans polizeibeamte verprügeln
weil sich von rechts kommen dann ist die
forderung da die müssen weggesperrt
werden auf lebenszeit und das macht
eigentlich die heuchelei aus
untereinander vom tatbestand hier ist
die polizei bei völlig egal ob von links
oder rechts raus auf die oft direkt auf
den helm krieg das ist der gleiche
straftatbestand und trotzdem wird er in
der einrichtung wegen der edlere motive
anders beurteilt als in der anderen
durch gewissen unterschied ob man sich
für rechte von diskriminierten
minderheiten in einer gesellschaft
einseitig eine nie die mehrheitsmeinung
auf seiner seite bekommt oder ob man
sich nur dafür einsetzt dass sich die
mehrheit gegen die minderheiten
durchsetzen diesen moralischen
unterschied muss man sehen obwohl sie in
dieser sache in ihrem beispiel rechts an
das eigene kind genauso wenig wie das
einsatzboot der rostige linken
geschäftsmodell der nacht muss man sagen
als ich die partei die linke sondern die
linke als politische bewegung immer so
zu tun als ob sie nie für eigene
interessen streiten würden eigene
freunde sondern immer nur für andere
unterdrückte minderheiten also zusammen
ist immer nur ein anwaltschaft für
andere argumentieren würde das habe ich
natürlich auch für gucken aber da habe
ich doch ein schönes plakat gegen gesetz
das hieße reichtum für alle
soviel debatte habe ich nie erlebt
dieses plakat
an übeln der debatte und ein übel das
glaube ich haben wir hier den defizit
ist doppelmoral und es gibt ein feines
gespür der leute dafür für diese für
doppelstandards und auch nicht glaube
ich das ist in das möglicherweise tief
angelegt auch eine große aversion das
macht ein caravan man weiß einer rede
besonders salbungsvoll ja und hält große
fenster reden und predigten und man ahnt
aber irgendwie arrangiert damit ja nur
eigenen machtansprüche bzw versucht
damit sich eine bessere position zu
verschaffen
das ist ja auch dieses ganze moral spiel
das ich immer versuche andere positionen
als moralisch minderwertig zu betrachten
noch dazu kommt ist und das ist glaube
ich wirklich ein problem das die die
sich zum anwalt der unterdrückten der
unterdrückten der opfer der anständigen
und so weiter machen denen manchmal auch
ein bärendienst erweisen ja also das
heißt in dem ich immer wieder auch sagen
das sind ja anständig und die sind ja so
diskriminiert und ist alles so
schrecklich und so hält man auch
bestimmte bevölkerungsgruppen in
gewisser weise klein schreibt sie auch
fest in der opferrolle und die frage
also das sind ja all die fragen die wir
diskutieren mit gender gerechter sprache
me to und so weiter also diese diese
widersprüchlichkeit zum teil in dieser
anwaltschaft die die glaube ich erleben
gerade und wenn ich das noch ganz kurz
sagen darf das meinte ich auch vorhin
als ich gesagt habe dass ich diese diese
diese der fortschritt der eigentlich in
der zunehmenden sensibilisierung das
dass wir da glaube ich jetzt gerade in
so einer bestimmten phase sind wo wir
uns eben fragen kippt das möglicherweise
um werden wir zu empfindlich müsste man
nicht eigentlich jetzt sagen ich will
jetzt gar nicht spezifizieren
aber die und die gruppe da kommt es
jetzt gar nicht mehr auf noch weiter
veränderte strukturen und eine noch
weiter veränderte sprache und quote und
so weiter an sondern da kommt es jetzt
möglicherweise eher auf die individuen
also dass die jetzt was draus machen aus
diesen möglichkeiten wenn es einmal zu
mir gesagt man muss das kapital von marx
umschreiben und zwar immer in weibliche
und männliche form mal abgesehen davon
das ist kein markt so nicht geschrieben
hatte aber ich gesagt dass es völlig
ahistorisch stellen wir das wirklich
rückwirkend machen würden würde keiner
mehr wissen welchen heldenhaften kampf
ihr geführt habe
bis es soweit war weil du musst doch
geschichte so belassen wie sie ist es
gab auch ausdrücke die früher nie
schlimm weil ich kann doch bush nicht
ändern
das heißt also den schriftsteller meine
ich jetzt ich muss es so belassen und
dann kann man gerne erklären wieso sich
das geändert hat erzählt
aber ich weiß was das thema wasser aus
dem grundgesetz betrifft wo ist meiner
meinung einfach auch nicht hingehört das
mag historisch kategorie aber es ist
eben auch das fundament einer oder
spiegelbild einer gesellschaft eine
verfassung und signalisiert hier auch
dass eine gesellschaft durchaus in der
lage ist sich zu verändern richtig
sodass grund geht er dann jedoch noch ja
aber da stehen sie das sein wird was
meines erachtens heute auch niemand mehr
verwenden muss definitiv nicht niemand
mehr verwenden muss und dementsprechend
die diese diese sprachpolizei oder diese
kritische haltung aber bestimmten wusste
ich dann mit dem mega könig bei astrid
lindgren
was ist mit dem zugeschnitten da würde
ich tatsächlich auch in richtung von
herrn gysi argumentieren dass es in der
geschichte bleibt aber erklärt wird mit
einer fußnote nicht in einem sternchen
erklärt wird dass dem kind erklärt wird
dieses wort wird heute nicht mehr
benutzt aber es ist es ist das original
wort in dieser geschichte ich sage ich
nutze das ist wieder etwas angriff so
dass sie so ein schnitzel das
zigeunerschnitzel muss heute meines
erachtens auch auf keiner speisekarte
mehr stehen wenn ich das schnitzel mit
paprika scharfer paprika zucchini
schreibe ist glaube ich schon jedem
bekannt aber wir haben wie immer ist sie
wenn ich nur ein ganz klein bisschen
sein dass man plötzlich ich bin ja gut
68 jahre und ich habe mir nicht nur
jungs und ich habe mir nur vorstellen
wie man sieht ist dass ich deutlich
geworden als musik und sie haben
unabhängig davon habe ich mir nie
vorstellen können dass ich obwohl ich
den 65 jahre lang den begriff negerkuss
gebraucht haben weil ich damit überhaupt
nicht verbunden haben egal ausmacht
sondern das war einfach negerkuss dass
man durch verwendung ist besonders
negativ übrigens zum rassisten wird hat
mich wirklich überrascht und ich sage
noch einmal nicht nicht nicht die doch
doch nicht gegen dich nicht der begriff
ist rassistisch anatolien hier ist
gekauft werden die ist gebrauchen sind
rassistisch
kann auch diese cent wort umschreiben
und bleibt trotzdem rassist ja aber ich
glaube die jesuiten orden
aber es ist ja nicht damit auf dass sie
sagen also wir wollen nicht mehr das n
wort benutzen wir sagen die meisten ok
sprache entwickelt sich es wenn leute
das beleidigen empfinden gebietes ist
die höflichkeit darauf zu verzichten so
dann sagst du also jetzt schwarzer kommt
da schon am nächsten tag der erste um
die ecke gewackelt sagt ja also schwarz
ist auch ein problem habe ich darf man
auch nicht mehr sagen jetzt geben ins
englische jetzt nehme das ganze people
of colour und da hängt ja was mich daran
so kann man einfach das kann man gibt
auf kalla
das soll die anderen so aber wir haben
europa ihnen daran ist nennen und das
ist etwas das ist so lustig dass es von
der linken kommt und wir sitzen ja mit
einem max ist hier am tisch oder eine
runde
magst wir natürlich nie auf die idee
gekommen zu sagen dass sich das sein
verändert nur weil wir da anders drüber
reden das aber genau die vorstellungen
die vorstellung ist wir alle gewöhnen an
seinen anderen sprachgebrauch an und
damit würde sich gewissermaßen der
aufklärerische zustand unsere
gesellschaft verändern und verbessern
und dann stellen natürlich auch diese
linken oben dann fest die
diskriminierung hat nicht aufgehört weil
wir anders über die dinge reden also
wird aber nicht versucht sozusagen an
die wurzel zu gehen sondern einen neuen
begriff zu finden weil der alte offenbar
untauglich war in der veränderung der
welt und deswegen kommen wir dazu dass
wir den ständig diese sprachspiele
spielen das ist dadurch animistische
denken letztlich magisches denken wir
reden über die wirklichkeit anders da
wird sich schon entscheiden sie wird
sich nicht ändern ich habe bei solchen
mails erreicht haben gesagt die chancen
natürlich auch selbst schwarz black live
später es ist doch damit würde ich von
meinem recht als diskussionsleiter gerne
gebrauch machen
ich finde das alles sehr interessant wir
haben jetzt sehr lange darüber
diskutiert was da alles falsch läuft in
der diskussion und inwiefern das
beigetragen hat zur spaltung dieser
gesellschaft die wir alle bedauert haben
ich würde jetzt interessieren blickt
nach vorne
wie kann man das denn überwinden also
sind wir den ganzen rettungslos
ausgesetzt twitter wird immer schlimmer
und so ist die gesellschaft die wirtin
immer die sparrate also wir können ja
nichts machen
oder kann man das
also kann man diese spaltung überwinden
ich ich sage jetzt mal einfach um sie
ganz persönlich was was machen sie zum
beispiel dass diese und gern auch von
ihnen allen anderen was machen sie denn
damit diese spaltung überwunden werden
kann
zwei sätze der erste wir müssen die
these die im raum steht dass die
grundrechte nicht wegen der pandemie
sondern aus anderen politischen gründen
eingeschränkt werden und das
aufrechterhalten bleibt zumindest zum
teil nach der pandemie hundertprozentig
widerlegen das heißt nach dem ende der
pandemie müssen wir alle grundrechte
vollständig wiederherstellen weil dann
haben wir eine lehre erteilt dass dieses
misstrauen gegen die politik nicht
stimmte so misstrauen bekämpfen was ist
was ist das ist denen spreche das ist
der unterschied was ich gut kann dass
das fängt damit an dass ich entgegen
meiner natur ihnen längere zeit zu hören
und dann aber versuche sie vom gegenteil
zu überzeugen
das ist sehr sehr schwer kostet mühe
aber es gibt immer zwei wege ich kann
der afg entgegenkommen und anfangen wie
sie zu reden in der hoffnung ich gewinne
die leute oder ich überzeuge die leute
vom gegenteil
der zweite weg ist schwieriger aber
meiner gehört zum zuhören auch der
glaube der könnte recht haben also hat
im zweifelsfall einer von der af der mit
ihnen diskutiert vielleicht auch mal
recht wenn er mich wirklich davon
überzeugt was ich mir schwer vorstellen
kann dann müsste ich das zugeben es hat
schon politiker anderer parteien im
bundestag gegeben die mit argumenten kam
weil ich ein anhänger von logik bin wo
ich sagte das ist logisch dass hast du
überhaupt nicht bedacht haben sein denkt
oder natürlich selten aber es kommt vor
und wenn es gar nicht mehr die
universelle bildung von gregor gar nicht
mehr wer kommt verstehen sie dann muss
man über sich selbst nach der politik
ganz große aufgabe zukommt und den
politikern einen wichtigen punkt hat
gregor gysi gesagt damit anfangen so zu
sprechen dass die leute überhaupt
verstehen wovon ich spreche also nicht
diesen ausflug in dieses in die pflege
auch in diese komische bürokraten
sprache das für mich verbindende themen
dieser sendung und durch alle mehr oder
weniger wortmeldungen ist
das gefühl vieler leute abgehängt und
man kann auch nicht nur kultur man kann
nicht nur sozial abgehängt man kann sie
auch kulturell abgehängt fühlen das
heißt das gefühl haben dass die leute da
oben weder meine lebenswirklichkeit
verstehen noch versuchen überhaupt sie
zu verstehen mir in jeder ihrer äußerung
sagen dass sie im grund einer anderen
elitären welt leben also machen wir uns
nichts vor
dieses gender sprechen was jetzt einzug
hält bis ihnen die heute-show modern
herr kind sich heute show ins heute
journal woher kleber an fängt jetzt ein
schluckauf zu sprechen ja von den
kritiker innen ja weil er denkt wem auch
immer er damit gefallen muss ganz viele
leute empfinden das als das ist eine
eliten sprache ich meine früher hat man
ein freund hat man am russischen hof
französisch gesprochen um sich
abzusetzen von den mob heute spricht man
gender sprache das ist doch eine sprache
die überhaupt nur zwei bis drei prozent
der deutschen ist verstehen und wissen
wir ob das konzept dahinter begreifen
es gab auch eine zeit da haben ganz
viele menschen auch überhaupt nicht
verstanden warum das mittel eines ist in
ein land zu zeigen ist noch nicht so
weit du wirst schon auf meinem
kenntnisstand kommen aber das ist noch
ich würde nur sagen es ist noch kein
hinreichendes argument sondern ein
hinreichendes argument wäre tatsächlich
zu erstens zu zeigen es er weist im
feminismus möglicherweise ein
bärendienst zweites hat sozusagen
logische widersprüche die eben auch
drittens in der sprache selber liegen
weil die sprache eben nicht alle
identitäten repräsentieren kann rein
logisch nicht also was mir fehlt und
auch bei ihnen fehlt ist einfach dieses
mal gehen auf eine andere sachliche
ebene und vielleicht direkt daran
anschließend weil die frage würde jetzt
leichter haben hier erstellen
rechtsextreme ich also ich würde ich
würde tatsächlich sagen ja es geht um zu
hören total
es geht aber auch ich will es mal so
sagen unberührbare bleiben also mal
berührbar bleiben in dem sinne dass ich
zumindest mal versuche zu verstehen
rational sondern wirklich mal zu
verschieden okay wie sieht er das also
wie sieht ein schwarzer wenn ich zum
beispiel negerkuss lage habe ich auch in
den 80er jahren gesagt wie stuhl und
tisch
aber wie ist das eigentlich für den also
wirklich mal zu versuchen mich da
einzufühlen und in dem sinne würde ich
sagen wir müssen uns wechselseitig
erziehen
zunächst einmal müssen wir feststellen
zwei drittel aller deutschen haben das
gefühl sie können sie zu bestimmten
themen nicht mehr frei öffentlich äußern
warum nicht weiß verboten wäre ich war
jetzt dazu hätten sondern weil bei
bestimmten äußerungen die falsch
verstanden oder müssen importiert werden
können sofort soziale folgeerscheinungen
angemahnt werden bis hin darf nicht mehr
auf den sender darf nicht mehr schreiben
da darfst du nicht mehr einkaufen mit
den leuten redet man nicht und wenn man
das gefühl hat man muss jetzt aufpassen
ob das was man sagt nach einem
seitenairbag vorn ist ja wenn man kein
widerspruch erleidet der zu sozusagen
eine folgewirkung führen können dann
lässt man es einfacher und das sind die
gefahr für die demokratie wie kommen wir
da raus durch sendungen wie diese dass
wir darüber sprechen und dadurch dass
demokraten ihre meinung tatsächlich frei
äußern und auch begreifen dass
tatsächlich nicht nicht die eigene
meinung immer die richtige sein muss man
ich habe in meinem leben erlebt wie
häufig ich meine meinung geändert aber
bald zu stahlwerten zu anderen dingen
mehr und ich kann als vizepräsident
sagen nicht jede rede von arag die
abgründe ist in der sache schlecht
im gegenteil es gibt sogar sehr gute
reden wenn die dann aufhören würden mit
letzten zwei sitzen noch mal zu erklären
ist aus einer einem schuld sein
dann könnte man da auch argumentieren
das ist wirklich weiß dies ist die
versuchen sich ihre die ernsthaftigkeit
mit der argumente aufnehmen könnten
immer durch diesen kontext die
auslandsschuld und ich war ich war auch
dringend davon tragen die höchsten der
afg gar nicht zu hören weil es die afg
ist oder man muss abgehakt die gar nicht
zu hören weil kfd ist wir haben quasi
jede reflex das egal was in der region
wieder redet er sonst eher schlechte
regne der anderen parteien er sonst nie
bei fall kriegt immer bei fall kriegt
wieder anfängt damit ich möchte
zurückweisen dass gerade von der von
rechts gesagt worden ist aber das kann
ich natürlich auch das immer
zurückgewiesen was von links gesagt
wurde aber zu ihm würde ich gerne ein
oder machen
es gab ein leserbrief der mich überzeugt
hat und zwar hat er eben einen kommentar
geschrieben er ist gegen das große i ich
übrigens auch ich sage immer einfach
beide als arbeiterinnen und arbeiter
oder arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
ich finde das auch nicht so schlimm
jetzt aber warum und dann gab es im
leserbrief also der kommentar bereiten
dass sich dagegen da schrieb eine frau
ist hatte er nicht mit dem kommentar
dazu und sagte also sieht dass ein dass
das wirklich quatsch alle frauen wissen
dass sie mit der menschlichen variante
auch gemeint sind das war jetzt tausende
jahre so und für die nächsten 1000 jahre
schlägt sie vor dass wir nur noch die
weibliche form benutzen und die männer
aber wissen sie sind mit gemeint und
dann heißt es ab heute das war ihr
schlusssatz herr rechtsanwältin gysi ich
wollte dich rechtzeitig fit werden und
so habe ich begriffen und seitdem
quatsch ich so kariert wie ich quatsche
gehört das war jetzt ein schönes
statement das hat aber die reihenfolge
insofern durcheinander gebracht weil uns
frau gila noch fehlt mit ihrem rezept
oder ihren persönlichen dreh an der
sache wie könnte man was an der spaltung
der gesellschaft die ja schon gesagt ich
kann nur nicht diese es ist ist sie
haben gerade gesagt es ist ein gefühl
gegen gefühle kann man schlecht fakten
halten ich kenne dieses gefühl nicht
teilen ich will es mal so sagen dass man
heute nicht viel weniger seine meinung
kundtun kann als das vielleicht vor ein
paar jahren noch der fall war die
einzige in der runde die als ausländerin
in diesem land geboren wurde und sehr
lange auch so aufgewachsen ist die sich
heute überhaupt nicht so fühlt aber eben
ihr das auch immer wieder in den
jugendjahren immer wieder auch mit
gegeben wurde und auch damals hieß es
schon immer man darf ja wohl noch sagen
dürfen also insofern kann ich das kann
ich das kann ich das wirklich nicht
nicht teilen
dass man heute viel weniger seine
meinung kundtun kann ich glaube eher das
gegenteil ist der fall
durch eben die medien die wir gerade
schon gesprochen haben dass man heute
viel mehr ab viel schneller seine
meinung an den mann bringt oder in die
öffentlichkeit zu sagen kann wir müssen
stärker zu hören da bin ich komplett bei
ihnen wir müssen auch die ddr meinung
des gegenüber zu lassen ohne diese
sofort zu adaptieren oder diese zu
übernehmen aber er hat natürlich auch
ein regelrecht und ich glaube es hängt
aber auch so bei kleinigkeiten an ob ich
eine maske tragen und das als als
meinungs- einschränkung der
meinungsfreiheit empfinde ob ich da noch
mitgehen muss oder ob ich da mit guten
argumenten durchaus den den unterschied
erklären kann weil ich glaube wenn wir
so anfangen zu argumentieren und dieser
satz sei mehr zum schluss noch erlaubt
dass eine maske die einschränkung der
meinungsfreiheit bedeutet wir freiheit
auch banalisieren und ich glaube das
dürfen wir eben auch nicht bestimmte
dinge die hard errungen wurden dazu
analysieren
es geht über meinungsäußerung hinweg
aber auch dinge wie wie lebt alles mit
mit versuchen mit dem selben standard
oder maßstabs und dieses statement
müssen wir jetzt nehmen als schlusswort
in dieser selbst
herzlichen dank sie alle ich würde gerne
schließen mit einem satz der
schriftstellerin marie von
ebner-eschenbach die hat nämlich gesagt
nicht jene die streiten sind zu fürchten
sondern jene die ausweichen
in diesem sinne herzlichen dank an sie
alle sie haben alles gemacht nur nicht
ausgewichen sie zuhause herzlichen dank
für ihr interesse
bleiben sie gesund
[Musik]